[Musique]
le jardin de l'état en pleine
effervescence depuis plusieurs jours les
agents du département nettoie plantes et
construisent les structures qui feront
les décors du bonheur des enfants
ce matin les agents du patrimoine
travaille à la réalisation de la
structure métallique des sapins à 3 ans
montés dans ses plus grands ça fait huit
mètres de haut elle a de la ba aussi il
s'en prend à 7 m 3 4 m moi je pense que
c'est un peu là à quoi que ce soit de ce
qu'il a fait pendant à peine de l'année
les agents oui c'est pas que les agents
du 16 au 23 décembre
la manifestation au bonheur des enfants
accueillera gratuitement le public dans
le jardin de l'état huit jours de fête
avec cette année le thème maisons et
jardins de compte
une manifestation qui demande la
participation de nombreux agents de la
collectivité qui dès aujourd'hui
travaillent déjà à la préparation de cet
événement
[Musique]